cuéntenos Cómo ha transcurrido esta
jornada en la capital ucraniana
Valentina y Andrés ha sido una jornada
bastante digamos extraña la población
amaneció con la expectativa de que cómo
iba a responder Vladimir Putin a este
primer año de guerra en el que no
obviamente no pudo cumplir esas
expectativas que tenía exactamente hace
un año según lo ha dicho el alcalde de
la ciudad al menos el 70% de la
población había intentado buscar otro
refugios o a otros Lugares cercanos a
kiev o al oeste del país nosotros vimos
gente pero vimos muy muy poca gente
Comparado con un día laboral un viernes
cualquiera especialmente en los últimos
meses cuando la gente había vuelto aquí
es también Vimos una cantidad de eventos
para recordar lo que ha sido este año y
especialmente no solamente a quienes han
fallecido o a los heridos durante esta
guerra sino también para manejar quienes
han defendido este país Así que hemos
visto al presidente en el centro en la
plaza de Santo Sofía dando
conmemorando y dando medallas de honor
algunos de los combatientes estuvimos
esta mañana también en la iglesia de San
Miguel de esas cúpulas doradas donde
también estaban haciendo homenaje y así
alrededor de la ciudad la gente
recordando con velas con flores yendo a
los lugares donde se recuerdan aquellas
personas que han fallecido defendiendo
al país que recordemos que no solamente
son militares o voluntarios que se
unieron a las defensas territoriales son
civiles son niños pero también gente que
trabajó como paramédico la gente que
trabajó en emergencias en rescatistas
Así que ha sido un día muy sentimental
muy sentido en la ciudad de kiev donde
no han sonado las alarmas ha sido una
gran sorpresa la gente dice que esta es
una de esas tantas Sorpresas del
Vladimir Putin que es impredecible y se
están preguntando que estará planeando
para los próximos días
usted ha estado cubriendo la guerra a lo
largo de estos 365 días la hemos visto
desde aquí nuestros televidentes también
la han visto en varios puntos de Ucrania
cuéntenos eso también tiene una carga
emocional Cómo ha sido su experiencia
como corresponsal de guerra allí en
Ucrania
ha sido ha sido 12 meses yo nunca había
cubierto Ucrania había sido muchos años
cubriendo conflictos en Oriente medio
pero era la primera vez cuando vine Me
dediqué a cubrir la historia humana la
tragedia humana millones de personas
intentando Buscar salir del país o
desplazándose dejando sus casas pero
realmente creo que en el momento que
entendimos la dimensión que tenía esta
guerra fue cuando se retiran por presión
de las tropas ucranianas las tropas
rusas de esta región de kiev y vemos
esos crímenes Y esa destrucción que
dejan en estas áreas cercanas en este
momento entendimos que la dimensión
humana y que los abusos y los atropellos
que había cometido Rusia eran algo que
que solamente nos recordaban a peores
atropellos que habíamos visto durante el
estado islámico En algunos momentos en
Siria y en Irak que fue muy doloroso
pero también vimos hemos visto esa parte
de la de la de la parte militar de cómo
teniendo menos hombres que las fuerzas
rusas teniendo incluso menos armas al
principio como la voluntad y la
determinación de las tropas ucranianas
muchos de ellos nunca habían tenido un
arma antes del comienzo de la guerra
fueron voluntarios que se apuntaron hace
un año para defender a su país apunta de
voluntad lograron defender y detener el
avance de esas tropas y hacerlos
retroceder recordemos que han retomado
regiones como la de la provincia la
capital de única capital de provincia
que tomaron un control que fue gerson
Cómo han llevado la estabilidad a otras
ciudades de Ucrania Nicolás una ciudad
que hemos cubierto enormemente que al
principio era asediada y atacada
constantemente hoy vive en una cierta
trancalidad esa angustia que vivían en
Nicolás la viven ahora tristemente en la
ciudad de gerson y hemos pero así hemos
visto No solamente la determinación de
los militares sino de la población que
en la medida que las circunstancias se
dan vuelven cuando pueden abren su
restaurantes abren sus vuelven a hacer
su vida en una acto que también es un
revolucionario es una es su manera de
luchar contra ese terror que querían
imponer desde Moscú Catalina usted no
estaba mencionando es esta resistencia
que no podemos negar es innegable la
resistencia que ha tenido no solo el
ejército ucraniano no solo el gobierno
ucraniano sino también el pueblo
ucraniano y hoy el presidente bolodimir
selensky pues hizo una intervención con
periodistas en el que dijo que ve una
victoria de Ucrania Inevitable si
occidente cumple con las promesas con
todo esto que se ha comprometido qué más
podemos decir de esta intervención del
mandatario
me impacta para lo que es América Latina
y para quienes hablamos español un
mensaje que manda a los mandatarios de
América Latina donde recordemos que hay
un parte de la población y algunos de
los mandatarios que han mantenido una
llamada neutralidad frente a una guerra
Clara donde hay un Invasor y un invadido
y ha dicho que él está dispuesto a ir a
hablar con estos mandatarios de América
Latina que está dispuesto a dejar
Ucrania recordemos que solamente lo ha
dejado en dos oportunidades cuando fue
Europa hace pocos días y cuando estuvo
en Estados Unidos pero dijo que estaba
dispuesto a ir a América Latina hablar
con los líderes para explicarles la
situación habló obviamente del apoyo
Internacional de la necesidad de que
continúen llegando esas armas Pero dijo
que ni siquiera era la el número de
armas sino la rapidez con la que lleguen
esas armas como ha venido diciendo las
autoridades ucranianas ellos necesitan
que llegan rápido por la situación
especialmente que vemos en la zona del
donbas y máxima ofensiva rusa de la que
se habla para las próximas semanas
cuando ya llegue la primavera Así que
fue muy enfático habló también de la
intermediación del presidente Turco
erdogan en estas negociaciones dijo que
lo había intentado pero que no era la
persona indicada en este momento Y así
fue mandando un mensaje país por país
también habló de los tribunales
internacionales para llevar a la
justicia a quienes han cometido estos
crímenes de guerra desde Rusia Empezando
por el presidente Vladimir Putin también
dijo que su día más doloroso durante
estos 365 días era el día que habían ido
abucha y habían descubierto realmente lo
que pasaría allí y que su día más feliz
de su vida Sería el día de esa Victoria
que como usted bien ha dicho él insiste
en que será más rápida de lo que la
gente piensa Catalina algo que llamó la
atención Es que no criticó el plan de
paz de China por el contrario dijo que
es bueno que china empiece a hablar de
Ucrania y saludó que Beijing respete la
integridad territorial de Ucrania un
tono distinto al de la Unión Europea que
criticó fuertemente la propuesta China
habló de China y es bien importante o
sea abrió creó un puente hacia china no
se fue en contra de ella es importante
para ellos que china empiece de cierta
manera a tener un papel bien o mal en
esta guerra ellos sienten que es así
como también habló sobre Israel por
ejemplo un país que en su momento no
quiso
intervenirski es judío Aquí hay una gran
comunidad judía y él lo dijo así y en su
momento dijo que habían tenido problemas
porque Israel No había querido realmente
como involucrarse o tener una mayor
participación pero que las relaciones
también se iban mejorando con los meses
Así que realmente no fue crítico con
ninguno de ellos excepto Obviamente con
con Rusia pero sí creo puentes y lazos
para ese apoyo internacional en una en
una rueda de prensa donde los
periodistas Escogidos fueron muy
selectivos muy pocos de ellos y de cada
una de las Naciones y partes del mundo
fueron invitados a hacerles preguntas a
un selensky que realmente Se le veía de
ciertamente ciertamente cansado se le
nota que lleva muchos días en decenas
decenas de reuniones recordemos que
solamente esta semana estuvieron aquí el
presidente Joe biden también ayer estaba
el presidente del gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez Así que ha tenido uno una una
carrera diplomática en estos últimos
días y también es bien importante cuando
él habla del apoyo de la Unión Europea
en todos estos meses que vienen por
delante especialmente no solamente con
las armas sino con su apoyo dentro para
apoyarlos dentro de toda esta dinámica
internacional
Catalina los meses que se vienen por
delante usted ya lo ha dicho le
agradecemos mucho su actualización y
también su testimonio desde aquí Eva
ahora nosotros nos vamos a harquiff que
es la segunda mayor ciudad de Ucrania y
que fue asediada por los ataques rusos
está ubicada a sólo pocos kilómetros de
Rusia Ahí vamos a conectar con nuestra
enviada especial Irene sabio Irene le
damos la bienvenida a este especial de
noticias Cuál es el ánimo del pueblo
ucraniano en harqui va un año del inicio
del conflicto
Buenas tardes Sí la verdad es que estas
ciudades son ya que resiste que ha
resistido la gente de aquí es muy
orgullosa de ser de esta ciudad y lo ha
demostrado en todos estos meses pero a
diferencia de lo que vimos en el 2014
cuando la guerra en el este era más
circunscrita Ahora se ve mucho más el
cansancio el agotamiento
la falta de Esperanza de las personas en
que este conflicto acabe sobre todo los
jóvenes los jóvenes que han vivido ya
años de pandemia que ahora se tuvieron
que enfrentar a un año de guerra y que
por tanto ven como su futuro sea de
alguna forma congelado y puede no pueden
continuar con su desarrollo con sus
estudios con su ingreso en el mundo
laboral de una forma normal como en
otras partes del mundo
Esta es la el humor un poco en esta
ciudad se ve cierta normalidad por
supuesto la gente de alguna forma
también nos ha dicho que se ha
acostumbrado a la guerra por tanto
durante la jornada han sonado las
sirenas en varias ocasiones las personas
no se inmutan ya no no no no manifiestan
sentimientos de miedo
por estos sonidos que que continúan
escuchando aquí en Jacob en jarquín pero
este la realidad es que los ánimos no
son muy altos Lamentablemente
Cuál es la situación que se vive por
ejemplo en las zonas que fueron
retomadas por las fuerzas ucranianas se
ha logrado de alguna forma recuperar la
cotidianidad
la verdad es que en la mayoría de las
zonas retomadas o sea esas zonas que
habían sido ocupadas por las tropas
rusas no hay ningún tipo de normalidad
hay zonas donde no hay agua no hay gas
no hay electricidad también hay pueblos
completamente
arrasados pueblos fantasmas donde ya no
vive nadie hay que señalar que se trata
en muchos casos de zonas Rurales donde
ya durante la ocupación se vivía cierto
aislamiento también era difícil
suministrarles e incluso medicinas
comida y Ahora siguen teniendo estos
problemas de vida cotidiana básica que
tardarán probablemente mucho tiempo en
algunos casos en recordar sobre todo
porque sigue habiendo una presión por
parte de las tropas rusas para avanzar
también en estas zonas hay algunas
localidades donde se han intensificado
nuevamente los bombardeos rusos Por lo
cual realmente no
puede hablarse de una normalidad en
muchas zonas También en esta región que
esa han sido retomadas a esto hay que
sumarle que también hay 29 localidades
que siguen bajo ocupación rusa Irene en
este momento sabemos que el don vass
concentra gran parte de los
enfrentamientos gran parte de los
bombardeos pero cuáles son otros frentes
con la situación compleja Por ejemplo
estamos hablando de bahamut que está
haciendo escenario de unas batallas
sumamente cruentas cuales la importancia
estratégica de esta ciudad
Pues sí creína basmud Boulevard en este
momento están siendo las zonas más
calientes porque es ahí donde las tropas
rusas están intentando desde hace semana
romper las líneas de defensa ucranianas
y lo que se está dando es un duelo que
no es solo un duelo de artillería sino
también combate de Infantería a menudos
apoyado por blindados y es aquí que
Ucrania hecha en falta esos tanques
prometidos por los aliados occidentales
y que aún no han llegado y por tanto
aquí tenemos una situación en esa zona
muy complicada sobre todo porque como
decías pajud Ese bajud es estratégica
por dos razones la primera es que el
avance sobre esta ciudad significaría
allanar también el camino hacia la toma
de otras importantes ciudades como
kramatosh islovians y la segunda es
simbólica porque el gobierno ucraniano
ha Comparado bajo muta stalingrado
referencia a la famosa batalla de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial y por tanto su
caída realmente sería un golpe muy duro
también para la moral del ejército
ucraniano
Irene Muchas gracias por este reporte
desde hard Kids sabemos que ha sido una
jornada intensa Entonces le agradecemos
mucho que nos acompañe en este
cubrimiento especial y dejar que nos
vamos a ir hasta la ciudad de bucha
porque bucha es una de estas urbes que
se ha convertido en símbolo de guerra a
raíz del descubrimiento en abril de 2022
de cientos de fosas comunes entonces
saludo a nuestra enviada especial
Emanuel jazz Emanuel cuéntenos
cómo se puede hablar de cotidianidad o
de normalidad en un territorio
fuertemente golpeado es la misma
pregunta que le hacía hace un momento a
nuestra enviada especial a harky fines
sabio
pues desde aquí quizás podéis oír
escuchar un poco unos ruidos ruidos de
reconstrucción
aquí por la noche ahora mismo puede
escuchar obreras y también civiles que
reconstruyen sus casas pero no podemos
realmente hablar de normalidad en esta
ciudad de de mucho hable por la tarde
con civiles con unas personas de
mucha y también de la ciudad muy cercana
de de
que hablaron de la periodo del tiempo de
la ocupación de la ocupación rusa y unas
personas vieron sus amigos sus colegas
asesinados torturados por por los las
tropas rusas y le pasaron el mes de
ocupación muy muy terrible Aquí también
también hablé con mujeres que me
contaron que estaban encerradas en
sótanos con con niños
sobre condiciones de vida muy dura con
personas viejas también y niños
enfermados y eso en estos casos también
se puede hablar incluyó con los con las
personas torturadas asesinadas también
se puede hablar de crímenes de guerra y
muchas sabemos ya sabemos que que al
menos
419 personas fueron asesinadas y este
este estos casos son crímenes de guerra
y
Ucrania intento de investigar
en total por el país
contamos más de 60 y 5000 casos de
crímenes de guerra y por eso también
Ucrania pide ayuda a la comunidad
internacional para para rascar para
investigar estos estos casos perdón